thank you for subscribing to vox there
are a million of you this is insane i
cannot believe there are three million
of you that's like one two three four
million i can't believe there's eight
million of you out there
[Music]
so i want to shout out tal lemming he is
the artist behind the typeface that we
have used in literally every single one
of our videos
which is balto i wanted it to feel like
uh
a friend who knows a lot about what
they're talking about because that's
what typefaces do you know they give the
tone to the words ben marriott's
tutorials are really helpful and i
especially used his paper cutout
tutorial for many of my collage videos
the uh uterus that i made
one internet resource that i use a lot
for like visual inspiration is design
inspiration
i hope that's how you say it
[Music]
i want to shout out lauren duree
he is a composer on apm i asked him if
you'd play some music for me and he
played a little jingle
i guess when you're making the music are
you ever thinking about where it's gonna
wind up
no
sometimes uh i'm feeling when writing oh
it could go to that type of
documentary for example but most of the
time i'm i'm wrong
for a lot of our videos that i've worked
on we use david rumsey's mac collection
and it just makes it so easy to see how
a region's borders have been recorded
through time i'd love to shout out geo
layers and the maker of geo layers which
is this incredible software that we use
to animate all our maps it's uh it's by
far like my favorite tool rick pralinger
who founded the preliminar archives
probably 20 years ago there was no
youtube in the year 2000 and it was
really hard to see moving images online
and especially
hard to see history online you can tell
that he's thought about this stuff for a
really long time we've only begun to
scratch the surface of what we can do
with old sounds and images a resource i
use a ton is newspapers.com it has
thousands of newspapers going back i
think to like the 1700s sometimes i use
factbase a lot it basically compiles
everything donald trump has ever said or
tweeted or written about and they're
doing the same for biden i want to shout
out the internet archive you can get
really beautiful high-res scans of books
and there is really no alternative
online to being able to search tv
captions
news programming in particular
is required by law in the united states
to have closed captioning for deaf
people and so the transcripts you're
seeing most of the time is the closed
captioning that we've pulled out of the
video stream and turned into a
searchable index how many servers do you
guys have like oh my gosh so many
[Music]
i'd really like to shout out
connectedpapers.com you can type in one
topic and then it gives you a specific
paper but not only that paper but like
other research papers connected to that
topic
worldradiohistory.com you go to the
website and it's it's rough to look at
but i have pretty much used this website
in every single
music related video i've made um
probably since 2016. and i wanted to
shout out the creators of after effects
they're the people that changed you know
movie and tv graphics from being these
million dollar machines to something you
could do on a personal computer we were
trying to make something where you could
understand the pieces that you're
fitting together
so that
you can create anything that you have in
your mind
and we were clearly at the right place
at the right time we had no idea that
there would be this rolling wave
of
digital video
adoption
that has lasted 30 years now
and and is still growing
uh there's a plugin i use for after
effects called motion2 yeah it's just
like a workflow type plug-in where
there's a lot of kind of small features
added into this little toolbar
so
aescripts.com is a library of scripts
and plugins that you can use over in
after effects and i think the most
useful one is the layer random shifter
script
i want to shout out the rights and
licensing team at vox media um who keep
us from
how do i say this they keep us from
doing things in our videos that
uh
people would not like in a in a law
related
yeah making sure that all the elements
we have in the video we
are able to use i think it's probably
like the best way to put it who on our
team gives you the most grief nope not
gonna do it
i'm gonna
i want to shout out our a amazing field
production crews freelancers who we have
great relationships with all over the
u.s and the world i want to shout out
pretty gupta who is a fixer who's worked
with us on several india videos it's
thanks to people like her that we get to
speak to people on the ground
and understand what's going on at a
deeper level i'm shouting out the styles
and standards team aka boxes copy
editors can you tell me if you can think
of any mistakes that our team makes over
and over again uh i mean they're just
little things like
the box styles not to use periods in us
or dc which comes up constantly that's
going to be my next tattoo i think so i
want to shout out the vox newsroom for
doing such an incredible job on covid
coverage this year they've just been a
really invaluable source i want to shout
out all the viewers around the world who
have contributed translations for our
videos some of our videos have gotten
upwards of 70 language translations i
can't even name so many languages off
the top of my head that is phenomenal
and i wanted to bank our first
subscriber will i first okay technically
he's our earliest remaining subscriber i
was coming over to vox from the polygon
and verge network of box media so when i
heard that there was a mainstream news
outlet coming from the same publisher i
was like yeah let me get on board here
right away anything that you would like
to see us cover more in future videos
reading box was always more of a u.s
focused thing obviously so if i had to
ask hey more canadian stories i would be
interested in that but that's more of a
very light wish
yeah i guess i have to shout out all the
people who
have worked at vox and have contributed
so so much to us
these people all taught me so much
during the course of my career here
i don't think there's anything else
accepted to say thank you thank you from
the bottom of our hearts for your
incredible archives for sticking with us
all these years for building this tool
that we use so much
[Music]
the the sheep noise that happens when
you get an error um is
dave c's mother
davis one of the developers on the team
he's still on the team fact he's the
last one of the original people who's
still directly on the team
um
and his mother just recorded the noise
with her mouth and just
and and
that's the noise